hey what's up guys it's marquez from the
mkbhd channel back with a quick video
coming at you on this cyber monday 2011.
so i hope you're getting your shopping
done in another tab uh but basically
this is just a quick giveaway video i
don't know if you remember or not but
when i did my review of the audio
technica ath m50s those headphones i
promise i would give away a pair if that
video reached 800 likes and it got about
500 likes on the first day which is
crazy and really awesome
but it actually finally did hit 800
likes so i'm gonna keep my promise and
actually give away a pair so i'm gonna
give you guys a week to leave a comment
on this video and uh one of the comments
will be selected as the winner uh now
i'm not going to produce a separate
video just for the winner that's going
to be announced on twitter and of course
i'll put up a on my second channel just
a quick video of me drawing a winner so
you guys know it's legit but uh he has a
great pair of headphones and i'm excited
to give away a pair especially because i
just hit also 20 000 subscribers on
youtube which is like a crazy milestone
i didn't really
expect to get this far but it's been a
crazy journey pretty awesome
as you guys know the pair of headphones
i'm giving away is definitely going to
be good for youtube so uh if you're
interested uh if you like this uh this
giveaway format by the way just give it
a thumbs up so that's basically it if
you have any questions feel free to send
me a dm on youtube uh if you have any
requests for me to do a future video i
have a couple of great videos coming up
and an interesting little
youtube tips video that's also coming
but anyway that's besides the point uh
get your comment entries in have a great
cyber monday have a great holiday season
and i'll talk to you guys later this
week in my next review video peace